so now I'd like to take a moment to
introduce myself I'm Carissa little and
I'm the associate director at the
Stanford center for professional
development I'm responsible for working
with Stanford faculty and industry
experts to create and bring professional
and executive education programs to
industry today I'd like to introduce you
to an esteemed colleague Neil declining
Neil Dasani is a co-founder of DC and
Inc a new internet security company
backed by some of the most influential
investors in Silicon Valley and New York
in the past Neil has served in a variety
of research development teaching and
managerial roles at Google Stanford
University
DoCoMo USA labs yield Lee and Bell core
now known as telcordia technologies well
Stanford Neal co-founded the Stanford
center for professional development
software security certification program
and now I'd like to turn the floor over
to Neal define great Thank You Carissa
so if everyone can hear me okay I'm
going to get underway with talking about
the growing threat and impact of what
they smell we're in in previous webinars
that I view and for Stanford I've talked
a little bit about this topic but I'll
be getting into a lot more detail today
and of course if folks have questions
throughout the presentation feel free to
just ask those as per the livemeeting
software and the team will make sure to
get them directed to me and I might be
some questions I can answer during the
presentation but I may answer a good
number of questions after the
presentation as well so please send them
in so one of the fundamental shifts that
let me just switch into the slides here
so there we go so one of the fundamental
shifts that's been taking place over the
past few years is is how malware gets
spread on the Internet
it used to mostly get spread as coming
as attachments to your email or in a
CodeRed or nimda style infecting a PC
and then infecting other machines via
the corporate lam but the way that a lot
of malware is being spread these days is
by web-based vectors and it's basically
via drive-by downloads so I'm going to
talk about web-based malware and how
works in a lot more detail but to just
provide a little bit of motivation and
pointers to some recent events as to why
we should care there's there's basically
you know three trends that have taken
place recently that I thought would be
useful to highlight with regards to the
spread of web-based malware so for those
of you that know what a botnet is a
botnet is a network of compromised
machines and these botnets are formed by
computers that are infected by malware
and one of the interesting trends that
that the community noticed as of say
last December is that the Zeus botnet
had started spreading very aggressively
via drive-by downloads
we're basically legitimate websites and
web pages would be infected and simply
when users would view pages on those
sites they would also get infected and
in this particular trend and instance
they would have their machines become
part of the Zeus botnet and their
machines would be used for all kinds of
malicious activities I'll talk a little
bit more about Zeus second area where
we've seen a pickup in the use of
web-based malware is for those of you
that were keeping track of the of the
news last December and this past January
you'll know that Google as well as a
large number of other companies were
attacked by some pretty sophisticated
attacks that seem to be coming out of
China one of the interesting things
about that very sophisticated attack is
that it used a number of different
attack vectors some of the attack
vectors that were used were traditional
emails with infected attachments but one
of the interesting things about the
Chinese base attacks is there were a
number of attacks where they would
target employees of the company they
would send emails to them they would
send emails to specific employees of the
company where the email would come from
a spoofed email address from a colleague
that that person knew and that email
would simply contain a link to a website
that the bad guys had infected with a
with a web-based malware attack
basically an infected web page that
would take advantage of a zero-day
vulnerability and Internet Explorer and
I'll show some some screenshots of
what such emails look like you know a
third a third trend that we've been
seeing recently is a uptick in malvert
izing attacks so malvert izing is a is
basically when bad guys use ad networks
to split to spread malware through at
and over the past six to eight months a
large number of folks have been impacted
by malvert izing attack so the New York
Times Facebook recently had now we're
spreading by an application called
farmtown a game
Yahoo Fox Google the number of these ad
networks have been you know impacted by
by Melbourne asthma attack so I'll talk
a little bit about more about malvert
izing attacks and how they work I'll
also spend some time talking about how
web-based businesses and web companies
that have a website presence can take
various mitigation steps to defend
themselves against web-based malware
I'll talk about prevention techniques
detection techniques containment and
recovery so that's the quick overview
before I get underway into talking into
into some of these topics I just want to
talk about the scope of the problem in
general so in the third quarter of last
year there were approximately six
hundred and forty thousand websites that
were infected by web-based malware in q4
of last year there were about five
hundred sixty thousand so basically
there's been a significant number of
websites on the internet that have been
getting accepted with web-based malware
and you know actually if you if you look
at them you know tapings blogs you'll
see a lot of statistics about these
things what this screenshot shows is the
number of unique web-based malware
infections that that we've catalogued
over the past say I believe six to eight
months so basically there's been over a
hundred and twenty five thousand unique
web-based malware infections that have
been catalogued and one of the one of
the interesting things that that we've
been making available to the community
is a you know continuously
updated report of what are the top 20
web-based malware infections that that
are spreading in any given week and so
you'll notice and I'm not quite sure how
good the resolution of this picture is
but there's a couple different web based
malware infection so one thing I should
mention is that as compared to most
traditional infection libraries that say
a traditional client-side antivirus
company will aggregate they typically
aggregate the malware binaries that
infect people species what this
infection library is doing is it's
infecting I'm sorry this infection
library is cataloging the pieces of
web-based code the JavaScript the
iframes etc that the bad guys inject
into legitimate websites and so you
you'll see there's a number of them
listed on here on this slide and what
they do in these attacks is they
typically source in some content from
the you know some malicious website so
you know there's a there's a over here
they're categorized by the domain names
and the domain names are all over the
place there are sometimes
constructed to look like legitimate
domain names like like web photo in
other cases the bad guys will squat on
domain names that look similar to
legitimate companies so if I go over to
the next slide we'll see a particular
entry in the infection library so this
is an entry for the Google Doc standard
info iframe so the bad guys have have
placed exploit code on this website
called Google Docs banner dot info and
they inject this iframe code into
legitimate websites and this this screen
here shows the iframe codes that the bad
guys inject so there's been over you
know 125,000 unique such samples and and
growing so so this is an example of code
that the bad guys inject into into
websites so so let me let me back up a
second and talk a little bit about the
Zeus botnet and then I'll talk a little
bit more about how are these bad guys
going about injecting you know this
malicious code you know most
javascript malicious how are they
injecting it into legitimate websites
limit let me talk about the Zeus botnet
first so so the Zeus botnet I mentioned
earlier in the in the introduction the
Zeus botnet has actually been around
since July 2007 but it has gotten much
more active over the past over the past
couple of years in June of 2009 for
instance it spread by compromising over
74,000 FTP accounts so if one
compromised is a site via FTP it
basically gives the attacker the ability
to inject whatever they want onto any
web page any existing web page or any
new web page they want to put on site
and so on the Zeus botnet infected
websites by compromising these FTP
accounts very often one can just do
password cracking on the FTP account
names and that's that's one good way to
get in this particular botnet affected a
lot of companies and affected various
banks it affected various technology
companies that affected um ecommerce
provider is it it also affected online
publishers today the Zeus botnet is
estimated to be on the order of millions
of machines and so I'll provide some
specific examples of the code that the
Zeus botnet used to infect web pages and
initiate drive-by downloads to users so
so what is it what is the process that
you know the Zeus botnet and/or the
attackers used to to plague the world
with drive-by downloads it's typically a
you know a process that works in a
couple steps their first step is to
either in inject malicious code into a
legitimate web page that's one way to do
it or they can direct the user to an
infected web page they can direct the
user to infect your web pages via a
multitude of means they can for instance
pop-up windows that look like fake
antivirus and get them to click on
windows that look like fake antivirus or
they could also send
phishing emails but phishing emails that
are a little bit different your
traditional phishing email is geared at
getting a user to go to a site and enter
their username and password so for
instance a traditional phishing attack
will look like a financial institution
and try to get the user to a page that
looks like that financial or
traditionally encourage the user to type
in the username and password but you
know that requires a lot of work for for
the victim and so what what bad guys do
because they want to get they want their
attack to be as Pervis possible they
started sending phishing like emails
which just simply contain links to
infected webpages and I'll show some
examples of all of these so that's
typically the first step that the first
step is to get the malicious code
deployed on to as many literate web
pages as possible the next step is once
once that code is deployed and a user
visits visits aside the question is how
do they get infected and what the what
the what the web-based malware code does
is it typically invokes some
vulnerability on the client-side for
instance it could take advantage of a
zero-day exploit against internet
explorer you know some buffer overflow
or some some unknown you know previously
unknown unpatched vulnerability in the
browser or more often what happened is
that because of the fact that browsers
use a lot of extensions they use the
Adobe PDF Reader they use flash that use
shockwave they use all these plugins to
help them render content and these
pieces of software are large in terms of
the number of lines of code and then
their complexity and that makes them
susceptible to security issues so
basically the bad guys can inject
web-based malware code that invokes
third party on client-side plugins and
then takes advantage of client-side
vulnerabilities in those plugins so
that's that's one one mechanism or in
other cases the bad guys will put up a
web page that will be socially
engineered to encourage a user to click
on a link that will then bring down the
malware so in that case one might term
it to be a
dangerous download as opposed to a
drive-by download simply because some
user interaction is necessary but that's
how that's how that's how you know these
things can be served once some client
type vulnerability is and so I'm going
to actually focus the rest of my
discussion on from the drive-by case
once some kind of client-side
vulnerability is invoked the bad guys
can then deliver shellcode to the to the
client machine to take control for those
of you that may have heard of shellcode
shellcode is simply a sequence of
machine instructions that can be used to
to take control of the machine and the
name comes from you know the bad guys if
they can quote-unquote get a shell or
get access to a command line or get
access to the operating systems command
prompt it they can basically do almost
whatever they want from that point and
so the shellcode is geared at is geared
at taking control of the machine once
the bad guys taking control of them
seeing what they typically do is they
send down some kind of a downloader it's
a piece of malware whose sole purpose in
life is to download another piece of
malware and the reason that the bad guys
do this is because it gives them a lot
of flexibility what they could do is use
the same download or use the same
client-side vulnerabilities pretty much
use the same attack take control of the
machine but then on day one they can
serve one kind of malware and on day two
they can serve another kind of malware
in fact there's a whole cyber criminal
underground where one bad guy pays
another to serve different malware you
know on different days to different
people so you can imagine on on day one
a bad guy might be interested in in
conducting a denial of service attack
against some other website and on
another case that might want to use it
might want to send spam on another case
that might want to use that machine to
to to log the users keystrokes and take
take their credentials so in any case
typically a downloader to get sent first
and then some other piece of malware
comes down which which does the the
actual bad thing and you know in some
cases there's just a download or a piece
of malware but in other cases there's
actually a sequence of malware downloads
so so by the way for those of you that
are interested in in botnets
and in malware one of the courses that
we teach here at Stanford is a emerging
threats and defenses course and in the
last rendition of the emerging threats
and defenses course there is an entire
section on botnets and malware so so if
you're in that feel free to check that
out in any case I think go ahead and
continue chatting more about drop-by
downloads and let me return to this
question of you know how how did the bad
guys inject malicious code and webpage
we mentioned that it's typically the
first step in mounting drive-by download
attacks but there's a there's a whole
variety of mechanisms that that an
attacker can use to inject malicious
code on a web page um so for instance I
I have I already mentioned one path
where if the bad guy can crack the FTP
credentials for a website that's one way
so in the lower right hand corner we
highlight compromising passwords as one
way that bad guys can take control of a
website and inject whatever code that
they want you know that's just that's
just one way though there's many others
so if we look at the the if we go to the
top right now software vulnerabilities
in web application is another is another
mechanism so there's been over the past
I'd say five to six years there's been a
big shift a big move to move a lot of
desktop applications to be web
applications instead and web
applications have software
vulnerabilities just like desktop
applications do except the
vulnerabilities are a little bit
different so traditional web application
software vulnerabilities include things
like sequel injection cross-site
scripting cross-site request forgery
cross-site script inclusion PHP include
attacks etc so um so these kinds of um
vulnerabilities are actually covered
very well in Stanford's 6or and web
applications course I've encouraged m1
to check those out I also publish a book
entitled foundations of security which
covers these kind of software
vulnerabilities very injured in a lot of
thankfully this is another another way
that the bad guys can inject malicious
vote on web pages it used to be the case
that sequel injection attacks an attack
in which bad guys can take advantage of
the fact that programmers may not
sanitize inputs to the website and
instead of submitting data into forums
they could try to submit database
commands and if they can construct it
just right they can actually get the
website and the web server to have the
database execute those commands and so
it used to be the case that sequel
injection attacks were primarily used to
steal data out of the database so
there's been some pretty significant
attacks in the past for instance a
credit card payment processor by the
name of card systems was um you know had
about over 40 million you know credit
card numbers exposed to attack and
hundreds of thousands stolen because the
bad guys used a sequel injection attack
to steal data out of the database but
more recently a lot of bad guys have
been using sequel injection attacks to
not steal data out of the database but
inject malicious content into the
database the goal there is that a lot of
websites happen to use content
management systems and those content
management systems store the content for
the website in a database and so the bad
guys by injecting content into the
database can can can effectively serve
web pages and parts of web pages that
are of their own choosing which may
include the kind of web based malware
that I talked about earlier so when I
gave a snippet of the google - google
data banner info iframe that's the kind
of code that the bad guys will inject
i'm sending out these kinds of web
application software vulnerabilities are
another another another way to infect a
site another interesting trend is
occurring due to the fact that a lot of
web 2.0 sites are using mashups and
widgets you know and one of the one of
the trends there is that in any given
website if you look at the web site it's
not just a web site in itself it's
bringing in a lot of content from a lot
of other places right it's bringing in
pictures from another side it's bringing
in or just using a piece of JavaScript
that's a traffic counter
or providing some other functionality
for the website and the idea is that if
that third-party resource that
third-party JavaScript that's the
traffic cover if that gets infected and
your website uses that well then your
website gets infected as well there's
also been things like DNS cache
poisoning attacks where for instance the
bad guys if on certain ISPs they can
take control of you know domain names
popular domain names you know like
Google Analytics or just other domain
names they can basically then start
serving whatever content they would want
and whatever website under those areas
that are serving content using the third
pie resources get get infected as well
finally there's also infrastructure
vulnerabilities so web hosting providers
may have a vulnerability in their
hosting platform or they may have
network vulnerabilities and that's
another vector that the bad guys use to
inject malicious code into web pages so
there's a lot of different ways and then
one point I want to make clear here that
is that even if a web site even if a web
site itself is built completely
quote-unquote secure the code for your
web site doesn't have any sequel
injection or cross-site scripting
attacks etc it can still get affected
because of the fact that the second that
you give up control of any part of the
site say to to a set of ads or to you
know or your use from third-party
resource then pretty much if that if
that resource gets infected so does your
web site even though all of your code
may end up being secure so it's really
important to not only take a
preventative approach and do things like
mitigate as many of these
vulnerabilities but to also make sure
that you employ mechanisms so that you
have ongoing monitoring and detection so
that if something one of the other
third-party resources that you're using
gets infected you know about it and can
take action so I had mentioned a whole
bunch of means that the bad guys can use
to inject drive-by download code but a
lot of times what bad guys can also do
is you know even if they don't want to
you know do the drive-by download all in
one step they can take advantage of a
third-party resource or pop up a window
on the user's machine that pops up a
fake
that's a popsicle window that looks like
a fake security tool right so this is an
example of one and what it the whole
goal of the attacker is to get the user
to click on this to get the full
protection or whatever it needs to be
and you know act as kind of a Trojan
horse to get permission to download
whatever software they want onto the
machine this is another fake av package
this this fake av window was used in a
malvert heisting attack on the New York
Times this past September for instance
so this is another threat vector I had
mentioned that bad guys can also use
phishing to to spread web-based malware
and these are two examples of emails
where the bad guy has constructed a
quote unquote phishing email but the
goal of the phishing email is not to
take the user to a web site to harness
the user name and password the goal is
simply to get the user to click on a
link in the message so for instance in
the left window it says you know there's
a bad guy who's social engineering to
figure out subject lines that are likely
to engage unsuspecting users and so this
subject says your address needs to be
confirmed and so the idea is that the
user clicks on this link in the email it
would allow them to confirm their email
address of course what it will really do
is you know initiate a drive-by download
and you know these kinds of attack
vectors were used in the Chinese attacks
against school and a number of other
companies where the bad guys you know
just wanted people to click on a link to
take advantage of a do road a
vulnerability Internet Explorer so
that's that's another example so the
whole goal is to get the user to a
website or to take advantage of the fact
that they're already on the little--it
website and take their machine how does
one do that at that point well once they
once they have taken control of a web
site and got the users to that kind of a
page they have they have you know
JavaScript and iframes and all kinds of
other things you know injected onto a
website this is an example of some
JavaScript that a bad guy may inject
into a web
site and it looks like a bunch of garble
um so you know for some webmasters may
might feel that that in itself is
suspicious but you know if you look at
if you look at a lot of web resources if
for instance you look at what a PayPal
Buy button looks like the code is pretty
complicated and you know has has um you
know code looking like elements but in
any case once this JavaScript gets
downloaded by the users browser it gets
executed and when it gets executed in
this particular case this piece of
JavaScript actually generate some more
JavaScript which generates a more
JavaScript and what it does is it ends
up producing some JavaScript that brings
in some content from a compromised IP so
by the way you know these are all real
attacks please don't go to these IP
addresses
please don't click on these please don't
really use this code but but the idea is
that once the user's browser get to this
particular URL it then on fingerprints
the user's browser their operating
system fingerprints what third-party
plugins they happen to be using and on
uses that as a as a as a platform to
infect the user's machine so for
instance let me just take a couple
examples from from some Zeus related
infections that that we noticed so um
there were a number of client type owner
abilities that Zeus related drive-by
downloads incurred and so what over here
we have the the common vulnerability
enumerations the CVE codes for the
various vulnerabilities and Acrobat
Reader that on that one particular
reduce infection took advantage of and
you'll see there's a there are a number
of buffer overflows and so by the way in
in Stanford's on writing secure code
course you know these kinds of overflow
vulnerabilities are covered in in much
more detail but the idea is that the bad
guys will use some JavaScript in there
in the web based malware attack to
fingerprint what version
the PDF reader is running on the machine
and so in this particular case actually
all the code has not been included on
this particular slide but you can see
that the bad guy I call the function PDF
start and it basically gets this you
know version string and then takes
different code tasks based on what the
Adobe PDF version is and the whole goal
is to figure out say what kind of
exploit to take advantage of and what
kind of cell code to deliver so the bad
guy you know into the code once it
interacts with users routine it
determines which shell code to send down
and it takes advantage of what are
called JavaScript keep sprite attack so
I think in a previous webinar that we
did Dan Bonet chatted a little bit about
Java sleeps spray attacks and we talked
about them in the Stanford courses in
more detail but the idea is that if one
decodes this this is a set of machine
language instructions that are geared at
taking control of the of the user's
machine subtopic and once this code has
been executed they can then execute
whatever code they would like so as an
example of some shell code once the
shell code goes down basically you know
a download or descent as I mentioned in
the case of Zeus one downloader that was
sent is an executable called 2k8
and it's a it's a pretty well-known
downloader if one looks it up on on
virustotal which is a you know a great
service that will either run a binary or
look up a binary half against multiple
antivirus engine it has reasonable
detection I think it was detected on say
20 or 30 or so out of 40 AV packages but
you know there's been many many
downloaders and many many pieces of
malware which which i've seen which have
had very very low detection against
traditional antivirus as well so um so
any case a download or a downloader gets
sent and you know then after that you
know another binary gets sent which does
the actual bad thing in this particular
case the binary gets sent that gets sent
down will join the Zeus botnet so if you
look at you know what is the network
traffic that that you know that gets
incurred or that takes place after the
the you know the you know non download
or piece of malware comes down you'll
see that it makes a HTTP GET request to
a particular IP address this IP address
is well known to be used by this botnet
and it it makes a request to this
controller script saying hey I'm a I'm a
bot on and please add me and please send
the instructions of what bad thing you
want me to do next so AB so so so then
comes such a sequence of instructions so
anyhow so I covered the five steps that
are involved in in having and taking
machines by drive-by downloads and over
in this case we got up to the point
where I showed that when I showed a
little bit about how the Machine joined
the botnet but once a joins botnet it
could do a whole bunch of other things
as well it could it could the malware
could be delivered that will hook other
processes to log all keystrokes such
those stuff that those keystrokes and
the user names and passwords that the
user types in can be sent to a block
master it could send out spam emails it
could install fake antivirus on the
user's machine so there's a lot of
Nevada such things that that can be done
um so um so I've talked about drive-by
downloads I talked about a number of
different uh you know injection vectors
and attack vectors I wanted to talk a
little bit about malvert izing as one so
malvert izing is an attack vector where
you know your site can be perfectly
secure but you're you're monetizing your
site by using ads on your site and one
way to think about this is that a site
even if its implementation is secure it
may have a certain set of structural
vulnerabilities and so you know using
ads on your site may be you know a quote
unquote structural vulnerability that
stuff's not a bad thing actually if you
think about a comparison to your home
for instance you might like to have a
screen door in your home and
and you know any any cop will tell you
that a lot of bad guys take advantage of
screen doors to burglarize places that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't have a
screen door that doesn't mean that you
should go to bars infrared your screen
door it just means that you may want to
have a security system that and you want
to and they wanna have a motion
detectors for that screen door so so so
so ads are not that at all they're there
you know advertising has helped helped
you know create so much content on the
internet and do a lot of great things
but but the bad guys can take advantage
of you know ad slots on little bit web
pages so for instance a malvert Iser
will do the following what they could do
is they could either um you know
compromised the account of an existing
advertiser on an ad network and decide
to start buying ad space with somebody
else's account and they can upload you
know malicious ads malicious ad code
that would result in these kinds of
drive-bys they could also sign up as a
new advertiser on an ad network say
perhaps a second or third-tier ad
network and um you know start to start
delivering ads that were really malware
drive-by downloads and that were
web-based of malware code you know the
bad guys are pretty creative what
they'll do is they'll do things like you
know sign up with a legitimate ad on
Wednesday and start you know having that
ad you know get shown on a bunch of
websites and then on Friday night or
Saturday morning they will replace the
legitimate ad with an ad that has code
that will result in that word or buy
downloads and of course they know that
many companies are slower to react on
the weekends because people are off and
so there they're there malvert eyes
meant attack will continue to get
distributed for longer than otherwise so
to show an example on you know of how
this could happen here is a example URL
trace this top part here is a iframe
that typically serves as an ad slot on a
website and you know we've done a little
bit of an automation on it but basically
it brings in the content from
some URL and the advertiser it's just
basically the ad networks URL and the ad
network will depending upon which IP is
making the request or which site it is
and what that said is about we'll figure
out what ads to serve and in you know
most cases the ads that will be served
will be good ads but in the case that
the bad guy has uploaded an ad it may
redirect to another place so for
instance this is an example of a real
attack site plan for comm and this you
know this particular quote unquote add
you know initiates a couple redirects it
redirects to another malicious site and
then redirects to basically a file on
this malicious domain called terms PDF
and this iframe basically becomes an I
becomes an iframe that sources in a PDF
file a malicious PDF file that will that
will result in having the PDF reader
invoked and will result in pretty much
in a number of things I talked about
earlier where you know the particular
version of the PDF reader will be
identified and some exploit code will be
served that will take control of the
take control and you know send down
shellcode take advantage of a
vulnerability in the PDF Reader and
infect the users machine on so that's an
example of malvert izing now what can
you do what can you do to solve these
problems
well there's a number of steps that one
can take to mitigate web-based malware
attacks I there's a and then basically
the DES pro tip eclis have five steps
one thing that you want to do is what
you want to assess you want to assess
what are the risks to your site you want
to know that given your kind of site
given what kind of structure to have
what kind of content it has on it what
kind of web applications it has running
on it like are you using WordPress
Drupal you know are you are you using
ads from various providers you want to
assess what is the risk of your site to
get infected by malware and then you
want to invest in a mitigation that
helps prevent attacks detect attacks
contain the attacks when they happen and
recover from them and on this slide I've
listed a whole variety of things that
can be done so in terms of
mention you should do everything you can
to make sure that your code is written
securely you should probably be doing
penetration testing attacks to to test
the strength of your web application so
that you can fix any of ulnar abilities
you can use tools like web application
firewalls which will look for attacks
coming in by a safe sequel injection or
cross-site scripting type Channel
one thing I mentioned about about all
these types of Defense's is there's
trade-offs between them so for instance
if you were to use a Web Application
Firewall it can prevent web-based
attacks against web applications but for
instance if the bad guy gets ahold of
the ftp password for your site the Web
Application Firewall may not do anything
about that
so in addition to taking preventative
steps it's important to also take steps
that employ detection so and finally I
should just mention that you know doing
you know in addition to assessing your
risk to malware that's it being attacked
by malware it's also usually a good step
to just do a general vulnerability
assessment understand what are the
vulnerabilities to web applications to
your peer network etc but in any case as
I mentioned there's no there's no
preventative technique that's foolproof
so it's important to also employ
detection techniques containment
techniques and recovery techniques and
one thing that you can do for detection
is that you know the worst possible case
is to have your site infected and not
know about it and or say have your
customers tell you about it so so it's
important to have monitoring for your
site so that you can be made aware of
when the site does get infected and so
one of the trends that's been occurring
is that popular search engines and
browsers have been blacklisting websites
when they get infected and you know this
has been happening to all kinds of
websites including yeah I mean you know
Business Week and Snapple and Round
Table Pizza they've all had their
website inspected at some point and
they've had their websites blacklisted
by by search engine providers such that
if you try to go to the website say via
the search engine it won't it won't take
you there directly it'll say you know
the site may harm your computer or it
you know if you try to go there directly
using a browser instead of showing
the site the site will will will
basically or the browser will give you a
red screen of death so in any case you
could sign up for blacklist monitoring
so that you can be informed if search
engine or browser block would see we
offer that for free at de Viacom we also
have premium malware monitoring services
so that you can be informed of an
infection before you're blacklisted
there's also containment technology from
available for free some some not and may
be I think the best thing to do at this
point since we're probably running a
little bit short on time is I'll just go
into a demo so you know there's a
there's an entire life cycle for
protecting one site for malware where
you want to assess detect contain
attacks and you want to for that shore
users if they're going to be safe when
they come to your site but let me let me
um let me just talk a little bit about
you each of these into a quick demo so
to do to get an assessment what one
thing you can do is one of things so you
know basically it we usually charge
folks for doing malware risk assessments
if you're attending this webinar we're
going to make available a malware
assessment to you for free but to get an
idea of what a malware risk assessment
is once it's run on your site it will it
will basically identify when there's
external resources being used to render
parts of your site whether that be
JavaScript iframes it'll look at the ad
and it will basically identify what is
the risk or likelihood that your website
might get infected by malware you know
through potentially no fault of your own
right it could just come from maybe X so
so that's a one thing you can do you can
assess the risk due to malware I
mentioned monitoring so if and when a
website gets infected you want to know
about it and so this is an example of of
a report that provides detection in this
case the site me tube TV got infected
and as a number of different infections
it has an infection where there's been
some malicious JavaScript it has an
infection where a worm called gum blower
that infected over eighty thousand web
servers last year with some polymorphic
JavaScript was placed on the site
so that's an example of what what
detection looks like then there's
containment there's technology that you
can deploy on your web server that will
automatically remediate and contain an
infection from being served to your
users you know if and when an infection
does occur so there's a free open-source
web server module that we make available
called mod anti-malware lite
it's an Apache module it's structured as
an Apache filter and what it will do is
that in case that your website gets
infected it'll block the malicious pages
there's also a more sophisticated
version of it it's called just mana
anti-malware and that will fully
quarantine malicious code on web pages
before it gets served so just to give it
a quick example of how that works you
know when so this diagram shows a web
server that is running mod anti-malware
that web server and all the web pages
and applications can be monitored
crawled regularly and analyzed for for
malware in the case that malware is
found of course you can imagine that a
report can be provided similar to what I
showed earlier but in the case that it's
infected on you know our back-end
servers can send over automatic
quarantine instructions to your web
server that will protect it from serving
malicious pages which will not only
protect the users but will also protect
the website from getting blacklisted by
major search engines and browsers and
then recover you of course want to
eliminate the the malware off the site
um but since we're running short on time
you know provide a pointer here and
maybe well to just provide some more
links to resources to if you've been
interested in this talk and you want to
learn more there's a free white paper
that we make available about drive-by
downloads and web based malware threats
you can you can check that out in
addition if you'd like to have a free
malware risk assessment done on your
site here's a here's a URL so that you
can you can get that um you know and I
can provide a couple other resources as
well um the you know so I in various
parts of the talk I mentioned that
Stanford has some great courses that
cover a number of the topics that I've
briefly mentioned in
covered in much more depth so you check
that link out in fact I've given a lot
of links I should check in with a
Stanford team props we could send like
an email to folks with all these links
so so they don't have to key all them in
and then of course in addition to the
Stanford program you know there's a
number of different courses there's
courses on emerging threats of Defense's
if you're in web applications and web
security 2.0 that enables you with
techniques to protect web 2.0
applications so we'll show you how to in
that course protect Facebook
applications how to protect other kinds
of mashups and Ajax applications that
you're building if you are interested in
learning more about web-based malware
specifically I'd recommend coming to add
a science homepage you can see the
infection library in real time you can
see the PowerPoint with threats for the
week you can also sign up for a Twitter
feed for you know new web-based malware
infections as they as they occur and
then finally of course there's my web
page where I make available you know a
lot of resources papers tox feel free to
check that as well in any case I hope
that you've you've enjoyed the past you
know 30 40 minutes and now going to turn
it back over to charissa to tell you a
little bit more about Stanford's
security certification programs thanks
Neil um well that was a very insightful
talk in fact I'm thinking that we at
Stanford should take advantage of the
resources that Neil's made available so
just a little bit of background about
the Stanford center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for close to 40
years and so we have reasonable
experience creating educational programs
to address the career-long needs of
engineers scientists technology
professionals managers and executives
and industry we're really pleased to be
offering the advanced computer security
certificate program and partnership with
Neal we created this certificate in
response to an increasing demand for
courses in this area the program is
really unique because it blends the
industry practical experience from
experts like Neal with the Stanford
theory and research from professors dan
Bonet and John Mitchell who are course
directors for the certificate you can
see them in the in the photograph there
on the slide the certificate was
designed to extend the Stanford
experience to
engineers and industry which resulted in
a fairly intensive program that includes
some hands-on lab activities as well so
here you can see the certificate has
three required courses and many
electives to choose from and topics
ranging from security protocols to web
security 2.0 six courses total are
needed to complete the certificate and
we also have a special elective called
software security foundation which is a
certificate and it don't write in case
you need to brush up on your
fundamentals these are all available
entirely online at any time from any
location there's no application required
and once you're enrolled you get 90 day
access to the materials and you can see
some some pricing and contact details
there as well so we'd really appreciate
your feedback on the following poll if
you could take a moment before we close
here today to indicate your level of
interest in the advanced computer
security courses give folks a few
minutes to answer
perfect thank you so much for your
feedback on that we really appreciate it
and so now we'd like to take a moment to
answer some of the questions that have
come into the queue and so I'm going to
turn it back over to Neil who is going
to answer some questions and if you have
other questions I'm feel free to ask
them now and Neil will be able to answer
them for you
very good thank you Krista actually
before I probably take questions one
thing I just wanted to do is give thanks
to two to folks at basins who helped put
together the presentation I'd like to
give a shout out to to fajn Demeter -
Rajesh Grune autumn and the entire I
they CNF CPD teams for helping us put
this together with that I'll take it
looks like there's one question that
came up the question is what does cv e
stand for cv e stands for common
vulnerability enumeration it is a
standard that was developed and promoted
by an organization called mitre along
with a number of partners industry
partners I believe it's basically a
standardized way to to categorize and
catalyze all kinds of software
vulnerabilities so yeah so so you can I
think their website is might org so you
can check that out there's also I
recommend checking out the National
vulnerability database if you go to
Google or any other search engine and
type in national vulnerability database
you'll see you know whole databases of
CDs it looks like there's a second
question that's come up and the question
is what is being done for industrial
devices since devices are migrating to
IP centric environment well well so
there's a lot of industrial devices out
there
I'm not quite sure exactly what kind of
devices the question is referring to but
you know there's there's a whole variety
of for instance security appliances that
one can use to defend one's corporate IP
infrastructure
ranging from ranging from devices that
provide URL filtering to defend
corporate employees um there's uh
there's there's um there's security
appliances that will also for instance
check whether or not you know any of the
machines on the corporate Internet might
be infected with a botnet um did you
know and I think that you know these
appliances are great usually if you're
at a very large enterprise it's pretty
young I mean some of these appliances
can can can be you know somewhat costly
but for a large enterprise that may make
sense in other in other cases there's
also been a very significant trend to
deploy more and more security services
as a utility and so if you think about
for instance of you know both some of
the free as well as the premium services
that they see and offers to help sites
deal with web-based malware they're made
available in a security as a service
fashion where you can just you know buy
them they operate quote-unquote from the
cloud you don't need to deploy an
appliance and it can it can be used by
it by all kinds of organizations in fact
just in terms of a larger trend just as
you know in the late 1800s and early
1900s when you know electricity was
getting deployed that the wealthiest of
corporations and individuals used to
keep electrical engineers on staff to
keep the electricity coming in and
what's happening on you know and so
today the analogy is that a lot of you
know wealthy individuals and large
companies keep security engineers on
staff to keep their corporate IT
infrastructure safe but what's happening
is that because of the deployment of
such devices and in security appliances
and because of the deployment of
offerings that can be made available in
a as a service fashion where we're
turning security services into utilities
as well and so so I think that's what
that's a wonderful trend and you know I
look forward to seeing more and more of
that happen so so I hope I answer that
question satisfactorily if not please
feel free to follow up
with me by email through the SPD team if
there's any other questions I'd be happy
to take them otherwise I'll turn it back
over to Carissa - to sum up
thanks so much Neal so I want to thank
everyone for joining us today as Neal
mentioned we do plan on making the video
of this presentation available shortly
and we'll be sending out an email to
announce when it's ready and that email
will include links to the resources that
that Neal referred to throughout the
presentation you can also print a PDF of
today's presentation by clicking the
handouts icon located in the top
navigation bar click the file you'd like
to download and then click download that
file also has links to all the resources
that Neal refer to and once again thank
you for participating today if anyone
has any final questions we'll hang out
for a few minutes and to them thanks
everyone